I've been having some sleep issues lately. I take the entourage. So the entourage for those
don't know it. That's CBD. That's a CBD product. It does not have any THC. It's just CBD
at night. And this only helps for a couple hours. So CBD, why would that help with sleeping?
Because it can really decrease inflammation in the brain and it can decrease glutevates in the
brain. So that's why I can help with sleeping. I tried in sonnetal and that did not help either.
So when sonnetal is a product for designs for help that has melatonin in it and passion flower
and cannabelle and some other herbs that could be relaxing. You have a melatonin that would that you
would recommend. I do I need to wait or should I wait till another cheek swab any suggestions.
So if the insomnetal didn't work at a higher dosage, then just melatonin probably
will be helpful for you. So whenever you have sleeping issues, you do want to dig to whatever
you have any issues. You want to try to dig to why. It's not like you have a deficiency in
passion flower or you have a deficiency in CBD or something like that. So what could be a cause
of sleep read issues? So if you can't fall asleep. So what helps you fall asleep is melatonin.
It is the release of melatonin by the petial gland and the petial gland stores melatonin and releases it
when there is a loss of light. So if you have the habit,
like a lady bed and staring at your phone or watching TV or something like that,
you aren't decreasing the light to the brain and stimulating the release of melatonin from the
petial gland by doing that. So that's counterproductive. So that can be an issue. So make sure that you are
going to bed when it gets dark out closing the shades, getting black out curtains if you have to see
if that will help. The other reason why you might have issues falling asleep is because you have excess
glutamate in the brain. So glutamate is a neurotransmitter that's excitatory, stimulates the brain, wakes you up
in the morning, glutamate is necessary. So it's not a bad thing but excess glutamate is a problem.
So look for glutamates in your diet. Are you eating any processed foods that have glutamates in it?
That's what modus glutamate is. That's a glutamate that stimulates
excitatory transmission of the brain. That's why they put it in food because it just wraps up your
brain and it goes, you go, whoa, this is really good. And it's just because you have a brain stimulation
when you eat that food. It has nothing to do with taste. So it's a taste enhancer
because it acts on the brain, not because it's actually enhancing the taste. So glutamates are
caused, are produced in your body through a breakdown of glutamate, which is an amino acid that's
found in any kind of protein. So excess glutamate can be bad for cancer patients because glutamate
can be a eater of cancer. But glutamate will break down to glutamate, especially if you have a lot of
genetic defects on your GAD gene, your GAD gene pathways. So you'll break down glutamate to glutamate
quite quickly. You'll have an excess of glutamate. So people that have OCD and anxiety and issues
and are ADD, ADHD typically have GAD defects and they break down glutamate any protein that they eat
into glutamate. I have that. That's why it talks about it. So
and those people tend to be quick thinkers and things but sometimes they have more difficulty falling
asleep. So you have to take precaution with that. Don't cut out the protein before bedtime. Things
like that. So if that's the issue. Another issue could be that I fall asleep but then I wake up and
I can't go back to sleep again. That is typically a cortisol issue. Cortisol is a hormone that's released
and made by the adrenal glands. So that's a totally different issue. So one test that's good to run
is the Dutch complete test because that does test for cortisol balance as well as other hormones.
That's something that we could look at and see where your cortisol balance is. So there's a lot of
things to look at when a person says they have sleep issue. There can be a lot of reasons because of that.
Not to mention just stress issues that you're thinking about too many things. I mean there's just
tons of techniques that you could work on to try to decrease your stress goal for a walk before
you go to bed that will help burn glutamate and glutamate and just call you out getting outside
before you go to bed that will just help call you and we have it begun to talk about
light stimulation from computers. I'm sitting here looking at a computer's computer screens any screen
your television your telephone is vibrating at a frequency of 60 hertz which is you know with a
high high super high beta wave and a normal beta wave reading a wink and alert wave that your brain
functions at is about 28 to 32 hertz. So you're stimulated your brain at a hyper wave. You have to
get down your brain has to get down to a theta wave which is about 10 hertz in order for you to fall
asleep. So if you are used to watching TV or looking at your phone your fire in your brain at 60
hertz it's really hard to get it down to a theta wave for you to get to fall asleep. So one other thing
is could you help you THC is available in your area legally that can help you relax and fall asleep.
There's other reasons that you could be awake if you have paid issues things like that THC could be
helpful for that. So really it's such an individual thing.